the tesla cyber truck is a beast in
terms of technical characteristics who
could be unimpressed by its dynamic
features here are a couple of reasons to
be impressed in comparison to other
trucks it provides more space greater
durability and superior performance it
has the capability of towing up to 14
000 pounds of weight not to mention that
it can accelerate from 0 to 60 miles per
hour in 2.9 seconds isn't that
incredible let's talk about the design
for a moment this is the point at which
the cyber truck receives contradicting
opinions some people think it's overly
basic while others think it's cool and
original this vehicle appears in a large
number of online memes as a result of
its unique design regardless of what the
general public believes we are
interested in learning what prominent
concept designers think and how they
intend to construct this vehicle
cybertruck was named concept car of the
year by automobile magazine in january
2020. despite that let's reveal some
outstanding concepts for tesla cyber
truck redesigns and modifications number
10 the tesla cyber truck camping stream
it incorporated an ai enhanced analytics
platform based in las vegas has launched
the cyberlander a camper overlander for
the tesla cyber truck this remarkable
camping alternative allows users to
bring a kitchen living room bedroom
bathroom and office with them wherever
they go leading in the ideal wilderness
and urban excursions the looks functions
and accompanying app of the cyber lander
are all intended to complement and
enhance the tesla cyber truck experience
the marble look porcelain kitchen
countertop on the cyber lander for
example replicates the dashboard on the
cyber truck cyberlander like the
cybertruck includes voice-activated
automation to control amenities such as
lights electrochromic dimming windows
and even the faucet the app may also be
used to operate these capabilities
deploy and store cyber lander and watch
the 360 degree surround surveillance
system number 9 the cyber series even
though the cyber truck has been unveiled
some people are still speculating about
whether it will be part of a series
marksman rifle a reddit user gave this
concept a shot with a representation of
the cyber s this variant of the cyber
truck has a more sports car feel thanks
to dropping the bumpers closer to the
ground perhaps a cyber version of the
tesla roadster was in the works who can
tell number eight tesla in the style of
tron when it comes to reworking the
cybertrucks commercial campaign we can't
think of a greater mix than tron and
tesla while tesla's official marketing
has a grittier cyberpunk tone a tone
that conjures up images of pickups being
used in a mad max style catastrophic
future the tron's neon grid block
aesthetics match so perfectly with the
cybertruck's straight line shape a
teaser poster like this one could be
released by tesla in the future as a way
to tease the public innovator david
sternberg came up with the idea for this
approach number seven the sports car
concept kaizeel saleem chose to add to
the cyber truck by combining the famous
lancia stratus and tesla's angular form
giving the concept a rally car
appearance saleem begins by considering
the characteristics of the cyber truck
design that distinguish it as a cyber
truck with its sharp lines and faceted
body panels saleem maintains the angular
bodywork while it is clear that this is
not the original cyber truck it is also
clear that this makeover is derived from
the same gene pool the design
incorporates wedge-shaped supercars
which are curiously evocative of
numerous pinewood derby cars seen at cub
scout gatherings a light bar over the
top and big knobby tires make it appear
as if this version of the cyber truck is
ready for off-roading adventures kaizeel
saleem is a 26 year old uk-based concept
artist whose work you might already be
familiar with if you played the latest
need for speed heat video game this
concept is a mashup between a rally car
a batmobile and a bertone classic number
6. armored concept the tesla cyber truck
would make an excellent armored vehicle
these concepts demonstrate the actual
military potential of a cyber truck the
tesla cyber truck is a one-of-a-kind
vehicle with various distinguishing
features everything about it is unusual
from its shape to its exoskeleton
tesla's body is likewise composed of
cold rolled steel which is the same
material used by spacex now imagine a
five-seater variant of the cyber truck
in which only the officer driver
navigator and gunner are needed in a
battle tank they have spooky door knobs
too a 360 degree tank cannon rotates on
the roof the rendering also includes
reloading bays on both sides which
eliminates the need to open the doors to
move supplies armor etc there is also
extra lighting on the front windscreen
and under the headlight bar although
these strong features may appear to be a
little excessive for a typical civilian
truck there is no doubt that it has the
potential to be employed as an armored
truck for various armies this truck
concept was designed by piecer design to
be a civil armored truck transport truck
combat truck and reconnaissance truck
havas germany redesigned the cyber truck
in four different armor styles this
includes the next humvee an armored
military transport vehicle equipped with
solar panels as well as other
capabilities the cyber truck combat tank
popularly known as the tank as well as a
military reconnaissance vehicle known as
the quiet scout number five the color
black with blue lights instagrammer
achilles is here has created a 3d
depiction of the new truck that
eliminates the steel shimmer and
replaces it with a black paint job as
well as using blue lights instead of the
standard white lights a redditor even
created an entire website that allows
you to customize the color of a cyber
truck as you like including the addition
of a metallic finish if you so desire
number four police concept the dubai
police department released an image on
twitter this picture depicts what a
cyber truck may look like if it was one
of their vehicles the ontario provincial
police previously unveiled the prototype
for a tesla model x police vehicle but
they are now considering using a tesla
cybertruck electric pickup truck as a
police patrol car according to the
company tesla automobiles are becoming
increasingly popular with police
departments all around the world
including in the united states number
three tesla cybertruck spacex moon hero
now as elon musk's companies tesla and
spacex expand their collaborations a
designer has drawn up renderings of what
a moon or mars roving cyber truck may
look like elon musk has even joked about
redesigning the cyber truck for space
ones so it's a weird design for a car
meant for another place however as a
reader on electric noted several of the
design cues here integrated actual
concerns about space for example the
rubber wheels of a cyber truck would
need to be replaced by metal in space
since rubber would get too cold and
brittle the use of electric vehicles for
space travel has a long history because
combustion engines are built to operate
in our atmosphere whereas electric
motors can generate torque in a far
wider range of environmental conditions
number two cybertruck in video games
games are clearly a passion for elon
musk the enormous size of the tesla
cyber truck makes it an ideal vehicle
for one of the video gamers most beloved
characters master chief who serves as
the main protagonist of the halo
franchise the overwatch video game
series is another one that he enjoys
very much consequently the future cyber
truck may be a perfect fit for the cyber
truck 2077 video game tesla cyber truck
effortlessly merges into the game's
cyberpunk environment which already has
vehicles with a similar style to tesla
number one tesla ironman design elon
musk has been dubbed the real life tony
stark perhaps this is what digital
vehicle artist john sebal had in mind
when he created this design he compares
it to the mk1 iron man outfit the
redesign contains the original planar
origami-like form but is just a bit
larger as many people have pointed out
this looks more like a regular pickup
truck than the genuine cyber truck but
it still has that wonderful cyberpunk
aesthetic conclusion one of the
cybertruck's most intriguing design
features is its sharp edged greenhouse
it gives the truck an instantly
recognizable profile there's no
confusing it with other trucks on the
market the highly anticipated tesla
cyber truck isn't set to go into
production until late 2021 but in the
meantime artists have been reimagining
the electric truck in different and
creative ways however we want you to
know what outstanding designers think
about this car and how they interpret it
in their own creations regardless of
what the general public thinks these are
excellent examples of tesla cyber truck
redesigns and alterations in the form of
artwork as earlier said there is no
shortage of cyber truck ideas floating
around the internet what other concepts
for cyber truck would you like to see in
the future have you come up with any
additional mind-blowing designs yet
please share your opinions with us in
the comments section in the meantime
please give this video a thumbs up if
you enjoyed it more information can be
found on the simply tech youtube channel
we'll see you in the next video